don't have never attempted to microwave
a wooden ball I have did a catch on fire
no no no microwaves work no all you need
to do is just not microwave metal right
yeah yeah well even aluminum safe unless
it's crunchy
oh no welcome to another episode of
trash taste guys I'm your host for today
gaunt and uh with me why are you
laughing joking I'm like wow we we
somehow tangented into the shop I forget
sometimes we just start talking like oh
the cameras are rolling I guess we need
to do the intro yeah
joining me once again are the boys thank
you thank you you look like you had
something to say I have an announcement
to make okay I watched anime I was okay
this is this is [__] weird right
because I was like I was about to say
I'm the host for today I'm hijacking
this show we're talking about anime
because it's been a while since we had
anime top uh anime title in one of our
episodes you know what's crazy Connor I
also watch that are you [__] for it
was it chainsaw man no I watched I
watched an anime film actually I watched
two anime films yesterday what is what
is going on what is going on over again
holy [__] I'm having flashbacks
the good old days all right um
I watched three shows oh [__]
I like how every time Joey talks about
anime my first reaction is really tell
me everything just tell me everything
that I'm watching anime
all right come on tell me okay so I
watched I just on a whim I think uh
because I was talking to my friend about
uh the late Satoshi Khan all right
easily one of the most like
groundbreaking influential unique anime
directors of all time and I thought to
myself I was like damn I haven't watched
a lot of Satoshi Khan in a while okay
okay and I thought to myself all right
I'm probably gonna try and find if there
are any Satoshi con films on Netflix
without some time uh the only one that
Netflix Japan has is Millennium actress
I thought that's good which is oh which
I was glad because I was like I've seen
perfect blue plenty of times to remember
it I've seen paprika enough times I've
seen tiger Godfathers Millennium actress
though I feel like I've only watched it
once and it was like decades ago yeah so
I was like all right perfect I'll like
refresh myself on Millennium mattress
because I literally don't remember
anything about it
[__] brilliant film like I know it
wasn't a surprise because it's Satoshi
wow biggest Revelation guys Joey
rediscovers that Millennium actress is
in fact a good movie yeah um but man
like re-watching that film just made me
real I mean for one it came out in 2001.
can you believe that it's a 22 year old
film no idea and it still looks [__]
incredible to this day yeah I mean
Millennium match I don't uh you said
about watching Satoshi con films he's
not made a bad film no I mean he's only
made four yeah exactly he's only made
four the only thing arguable about him
making a bad film is probably dream
machine because he didn't finish because
he didn't get to finish that that's the
closest he's come to making a bad film
can you can you imagine just having such
a perfect filmography that your only bad
entry is the one that you didn't finish
because you died before it finished
what's he up to is he just like living
off the wages of those four no he's uh
he's dead he's dead
yeah he died like 10
yeah I mean unfortunately he is one of
the greatest tragedies in the anime
industry because I don't know anything
about him I just know that he made the
films that people like yeah yeah
I've seen um
right right that was very good I think I
spoke about it on trash tags yeah yes
you did I really like that film I didn't
know who's dead yeah yeah
unfortunately like he is in all of anime
history probably one of the most
talented directors and filmmakers to
ever come out of Japan
um and he has made stuff that has not
only like aged wonderfully he was he was
like years ahead of his time he was so
ahead of his time that Hollywood film
directors has taken his ideas and some
of his in individual scenes and put them
into their own Hollywood films I mean
there are literally like some scenes in
Requiem for a Dream that are just a
one-to-one copy of scenes from perfectly
yeah yeah exactly
um how did he die he died of prostate
cancer yeah
um but yeah so Millennium actress is his
second film the one he did after perfect
blue that was his first film you know
that was his first film how do some
people just wake up and just immediately
hit oh no I don't make a film and yeah
it's gonna change everything he
literally just woke up one day and was
like I'm gonna make one of the greatest
anime films ever like men you gotta
train so hard to get like there's many
wakes up he's like I'm gonna make a film
there's gonna be well I'm sure you're
trained a lot but I'm just joking but
it's insane that his first film is that
good did you know that he actually did
some scenes in Akira of course he did
yeah but um anyway so yeah I rewatched
rewatch Millennium actress basically to
to sum up the film it's so hard to sum
up a Satoshi Khan film but basically
Millennium actress is about this actress
who is like you know past her prime
think it's like 70-year career or
something and she uh films this
documentary about her life reflecting on
her life and how she went into the
acting industry because she met this
random dude who he she doesn't know the
name of doesn't even remember the face
of but it was basically her first love
okay when she was a child
um and so she goes into the acting in a
world in the hopes that she can get
famous enough that the guy will
recognize her on the big screen and that
they can meet again essentially
um but what is so brilliant about this
film is the fact that like every Satoshi
Khan film it's he does this brilliant
job of like mixing in different Realms
of reality throughout the movie so it's
like you watch a scene in Millennium
actress and you go okay is this just a
scene out of a movie she acted in or is
this a metaphor for what was going on in
a real life at the time or is it
actually a depiction of original most
teachers be like no but like you know I
mean
as cliche as it sounds though like it is
fun it's purely like that and the way
that like Satoshi Khan transitions into
these scenes like you could be getting
used to one scene and then half a second
later it transitions into a completely
different film and the entire time
you're like
is this a recreation of the movie she
was in or is this her telling her story
through the movies that she was in yeah
I think one thing that makes him just
sort of [__] genius in terms of like
cinematography and just a Storyteller is
that the way he is able to transition
between scenes is
completely seamless yeah it's unreal
um and he uses this in such an
interesting way in films like Millennium
actress and perfect blue where I think
Millennium actress
um is she tells her life story but she
tells you you see her life story through
the lens of basically a movie right
um and it's got references to a lot of
movies and a lot of different genres so
it's kind of this you going in and out
of reality being like Oh you're
wondering if this scene that she's
showing us is a movie that she acted in
or is it a scene that happened in her
actual life and there's no real you know
it's there's no real line between what
is real and what is on film but yeah
it's just the way he uses that as a way
to tell her life story it's just [__]
genius yeah and it's like and it's this
other brilliant thing and I picked up so
many new things about Millennium actress
I didn't pick up the first time around
like for example like you know the first
half of the film you know as she's
telling her life story of like I met
this guy I you know I fell in love with
him I went to the big city to you know
pursue a career to you know to hopefully
meet him one day and I did all of these
different kinds of movies and you know
built up these roles and went through
these hardships of becoming a big
actress and then the second half of the
movie uses those exact same scenes and
the in but in a completely different
context so basically he somehow as you
get to know about this actress and the
hardships which she went through in her
real life they then replay a lot of
those scenes in the second half but now
you're looking at it through the lens of
her real life off the screen oh I see I
see and so and and so like you know for
anyone who's watched Millennium actress
you'd know the first literally the first
scene of the film and the last scene of
the film is the exact same scene but the
context behind it is completely flipped
on its head it's pretty cool you watch
the first scene and you're like oh this
is a movie this is in the context of a
movie she's in a space suit and she's
going to space saying you know I have to
go and meet this person right and it's
only in the context of film and you know
it's in the context of a film but then
they reuse that exact same scene with
the exact same dialogue and now it means
something completely different that's
cool and he does it I don't know how the
[__] he did it but he made that so
seamless throughout an hour and 20 long
movie like it's not a long movie at all
I remember when films just be an hour
and 20. yeah right oh
um I feel so meaningless to be like hey
this amazing experience give it a score
out of 10. oh [__] I mean is it like is
it like would you say it's like as close
to a perfect film in your mind is it on
Beyond giving scores
well I think you explain this like
amazing thing and I'm like aha give
score see because like IGN score eight
out of ten please it actually made made
me like want to make a video of like uh
Satoshi con worse to best but like then
I realized after watching Millennium
actress I was like he doesn't have a
worst yeah like it's it's like literally
the most perfect what do you say
filmography best from bestest then yeah
least least strongest yeah most
strongest any of them are not strong
yeah
but like I just like you know I kind of
just like rediscovered like why I love
this guy's films and even like the manga
that I thought I'd say I've rediscovered
what I love
no I always have that no I could never I
could never but like it made me and so
like uh over the next 10 seconds yeah
yeah oh by the way change the Montana
ten obviously okay I'm mocking my wolf
off
uh then uh then I was like uh I also
watched a new film this time I watched
uh this movie called ride the wave which
is uh masaki USA's latest film uh I say
latest film because it came out in like
2021 I think yeah um I I I I didn't get
to see the cinema I could be totally
wrong I thought that looked like ass am
I am I crazy
you think I I saw the trailer and I
thought nah dog not for me no I mean I
think am I crazy I think out of us I
think out of like Us's filmography it's
probably one of his prettiest films wait
no wait crap is he the guy who makes the
same movie and over again or is it a
different guy no that's uh that's my
Turkish he makes the same movie yeah
yeah I can't watch it USA is the one who
did double man cry baby yeah oh okay cry
baby ping pong the animation I feel like
I saw the trailer for this film and I
thought I I don't get it okay I have I
have two reactions when I see a uasa
film yeah uh my first reaction is what
the [__] okay did someone Reign him in
with the plot for this because if he let
me masaki you asked to do what he wants
it just goes a direction where you're
like uh-up
man that's what happens just like what
the [__] is this like I remember
watching uh I think it's uh I can't
remember the name of the film mind game
yeah uh
never heard of anime okay yeah mind game
I don't even know how to explain that to
someone who what the film let alone
someone who hasn't watched the film
uh basically he's a bad [__] insane
director okay okay yeah so I'm I'm gonna
I'm gonna say some scenes of Mind Games
that I remember out of context devil man
cry baby right there yeah devil man cry
baby was what I think one of his works
that made the most amount of sense yeah
okay so even though so mind game starts
off with a guy confessing to a girl
um and then I think the girl does
something he's in a bar and then he gets
shot
um and then he dies and he sees God who
is a goldfish
um who gives him another chance at life
he reincarnates and then he runs off
gets swallowed by a massive whale
and he lives in the whale's stomach for
like months and months with an old man
and a girl
um you're literally just bringing back
memories I was like I was like yes that
is in fact what happened and then they
they have this like dance scene this
this will this will live rent free in my
mind for ages they have this dance scene
where they have like massive poles
coming out of their dicks and they're
playing they're playing like hula with
it or something or some [__] like that
oh my God and then at the end of the
film he escapes the whale and uh that
was spoilers for mind game but is it
really spoilers
it's like if we explain the next JoJo
part out of context it's like it still
doesn't make sense like that was all out
of context yeah that made no sense in
context I would say though ride the wave
is probably well I mean I think with my
game did he also co-write that oh
[__] I hope he did otherwise I'm
worried for whoever wrote main game but
basically right the wave is like I would
say it's probably one of the most uh
like cohesive USA films right um it's
it's very straightforward just like it's
a really cute film yeah um so basically
you make cute things yeah I know I was
actually also surprised I was like this
it was so cute to the point where it
didn't feel like a you lost a film but
uh basically the story is uh the the
main goal is this like surfer chick
um and she meets this uh guy who's like
a firefighter one day and after he saves
her from a house fire yeah and then they
fall in love uh that you know they get
together and then the guys are spoiler
alert for right away uh the guy drowns
from a surfing accent and basically
she's really torn up about it because
like that was like her first film and
everything and then and then what
happens is and then what happens is is
that uh after that she starts to see
visions of him inside the water yeah
very cute so the point where she can
actually summon him in like a water form
out in the real world and like interact
with them as if he was still alive
and it's basically this idea of like
it's cold right of the way because it's
kind of like a double entender of like
obviously right in the way of like
literally Surfer Dude hell yeah right
but it's also but it's also like riding
the wave of like your life of like you
know stuff happens [__] happens you miss
that first wave but the next wave is
Gonna Come so you know you have to move
on with your life and it's a very like
it's a very simple straightforward like
romantic drama
um but obviously with like U.S uh
Aesthetics thrown into it so like the
character designs are very you are sir
yeah the animation style is just [__]
whacked out because science sorrow was
on some cracks as they usually are
um and yeah I'd say like it's definitely
not like a USA film but it had hints of
USA and I think it's probably the most
like approachable us of film if that
makes sense like I would show that over
something like you know uh to Tommy
Galaxy or something yeah I mean some of
his most approachable stuff is probably
ping pong the animation and Dove mag cry
baby yeah
um I'd say it's more approachable than
that to be honest oh really yeah I would
say like Aesthetics wise and just like
theming wise like if you've never heard
of a USA film I'd be like start off with
this and if you Vibe with this then you
can go to like Ping Pong or whatever why
does he want his [__] to be so ugly I
don't like why is ping pong as ugly as
it is uh on purpose I'd say so this is
like wean out like fake normally it's
just it's just a [__] unique art
style and yeah the more the more open
you need the more I've watched anime the
more I [__] respect it no I like it I
like it but I just wonder like God damn
this is so ugly like intentional yeah
like why I mean I think there are some
pretty ugly moments in the story you
know where you kind of like some you
have some characters that have this
realization that life is just [__]
shitty man life ain't Fair life ain't
shitty sometimes it's [__] ugly I
mean yeah I mean after like you know you
wash hundreds and thousands of shows and
movies like it's the it's the ugly ones
that you remember oh my God like I just
I like with the amount of anime I like
watched have watched over the like the
past few years the amount of light novel
adaptations that looks that look like a
copy paste it's I'm [__] tired of
that [__] yeah it's like oh here's
Kirito clone number 307 so every light
novel protagonist looks the [__]
saying so do the waifus as well it's the
same it's always the same bright light
novel-esque character designs and
there's no variation in it yeah at all
and I just like seeing something like
you know ping pong the animation uh like
Dove mag cry baby it's just it's it's
nice just to see something different
sometimes yeah yeah what have you been
watching Connor
um so I finished chainsaw man which is
great yeah there's not really much to
say other than can I have more please
yep wow that's pretty much we are
getting some more yeah I know I mean
it's like yeah it's [__] amazing and
yeah it's good and you should watch it
and it's worth the hype and yeah don't
don't be a don't do what Joey does
sometimes and just be like it's too
popular to be fair I did watch it again
even even even Joey couldn't couldn't
even Joey couldn't resist that he
couldn't resist it was coded as a
Fujimoto fan I had to all right uh I
watched four episodes of blue lock oh
yeah and then I'm done I think I'm out
really I think it's just it's too boring
it's really so [__] oh you think blue
looks [__] I really enjoyed it yeah why
do you think it was [__] oh my god
um was it the sports element or I kind
of wish people would just die that would
be much better if people just died when
they got kicked out and make it way more
interesting so you won squid game
basically I just figured if they didn't
go that's a completely different [__]
TV series
if that's what you want okay okay watch
blue luck right watch blue lock right
and tell me me if they didn't change it
so that they died that the characters
would act any different they would be
the exact same the characters pretend
like they're literally about to die
anyway if they don't score this goal or
if they don't like win this thing so I'm
like just [__] kill them well is that
some [__] stage I don't think not
playing for the Japanese team is that
bad okay sue me why is he acting like
his Lions Crush but that's the thing all
these characters in blue log that is
their life of like the wanting to get to
that team so then that is the life and
death that's the whole point of every
Sports Anime is that every Sports anime
character don't have a life outside of
that yeah exactly I was like I think
ping pong is like the one exception
I'm tired of it I watched it I'm like oh
great these are four characters that I
could say that they copy pasted from
like five like half the characters feel
like they're like copy paste from
yomushu pedal like there's so many other
characters in it as well that feel like
I'm watching like an amalgamation of
Croco no basket and then uh yomoshu
pedal and other sports anime just
conglomerates
so why don't you care if other sports
anime characters I think I'm just done I
think I'm done with Sports Anime and I
think this is okay okay that's that's
fine because I I like blue log just
because you know no one dies in it as no
one really does in Sports Anime you know
I don't really go into Sports Anime
thinking people are gonna die I like
blue lock because all most Sports Anime
is about oh guys let's let's all play
together let's win with the power of
friendship and teamwork and who looks
like [__] that [__] you go out in there
to be selfish yeah and be like
egotistical yeah [__] together that's
what pissed me off is that they they did
this and they pushed this and then
they're like okay now play as a team and
then you're like what and then now they
have to figure out no but then but then
that's the that creates an interesting
Dynamic of a bunch of people who are
trying to kick each other off while also
trying to work as a team so that Dynamic
is interesting but It ultimately just
came down to like okay this is the cash
uh this is gonna be the team and they're
gonna learn to work together and by the
way uh that's the show is not about that
and it's about not working together and
being the person who does all the work I
just got pissed off I was like it just
feels like there's so many
contradictions and then not to be be
that guy but oh my God whenever they had
3G 3D shots I was like what the [__] is
that that [__] was hideous well don't
tell me that okay everyone try to shoot
and change someone for the 3D dude but
blue lock had some ass 3D well I I also
don't want to be that guy but the market
was better of course the manga was
better I'm watching this
this holy [__]
[__] the manga is better it is like I I
ran ahead I'm literally sitting next to
anime Twitter like literally I went
ahead
no no
what happened was is that there was so
much other [__] I didn't like yeah then
now I won't make excuses in my head for
the [__] 3D right like if it was good I
would ignore the 3D but when they do
those overhead shots where they pass the
ball and everyone's just static and like
they're shitty 3D models I'm like this
is so ass I can't do this and like I
would not even think it was that bad
being honest I don't ever remember I
think I was just pissed off from how
annoyed I was at the story that it made
me more angry and like I I just hated it
I just thought it was like because like
I liked the part I liked about blue lock
was that they didn't kill them because
I'm so [__] because I'm so [__]
sick of these like death game [__]
animes that have like I mean it's like
oh guys I mean they did oh my God they
killed someone I do want to say that
it's just me being like [__] dumb no
I get it I just think that like I just
man it felt so slow as well like it felt
like nothing happened really all the
time yeah I felt like four episodes yeah
it felt like barely anything had
happened that's really funny because I
think in terms of like normal Sports
Anime pacing blue lock is really fast
paced compared to a lot of sports around
me yeah like especially the first four
episodes of blue log I [__] enjoyed
the [__] out of blue lock uh Adam and I
am enjoying the [__] out of blue lock uh
just because it's just a different take
on Sports Anime I think it's a lot fun
maybe you're just done with Sports Anime
uh because yeah I mean I'm done with I
just think the whole
the whole way it's done is kind of lame
uh yeah I mean I'm like very few looks
not my like I've I did realize something
after watching blue lock and another
football anime this year owl uh awashi
which is like a production IG Sports
Anime about football
um which is like more traditional Sports
style I realize [__]
I I think I just enjoyed watching real
sport now because God [__] damn going
from watching blue log to watching the
World Cup I was like this is so much
better what why am I watching sports
anime what I could be watching the
[__] World Cup you're seeing Japan's
Ark in the World Cup seeing the [__]
that happened in Japan as much as her
that was way more excited than anything
that happened in the World
Cups
you know [__] I think also uh what
really uh I don't know why this kind of
turned me off so much when they all
started [__] talking about how they
have like a in blue lock right so it's
football but some of the characters have
just monsters inside of them and I'm
like nah nah I'm done I'm like that's
I'm I'm like this [__] I like that
it's uh it's schizophrenia actually yeah
yeah it's like it's like oh why did you
pass me the monster told me I'm like
shut the [__] up can you not just be
good at the [__] sport why do you
have to have some schizophrenic tendency
for you to be remotely even interesting
as a character like why do why it needs
to be that or some kind of like [__]
superpower okay like why why for me to
care about a character do you have to be
schizophrenic and have funny hair like I
just I just come on like there's got to
be better ways to write these characters
so I'm saying man that's why slam dunk
is the goat and they don't have any of
that yeah and then like the second the
fourth episode the one I kind of clocked
out they were like against this team I
don't know why it pissed me off this
main character should hentai hair and I
was like I'm just why I'm just I don't
know why it's pissed me off I'm like
it's just a [__] he has a [__]
hentai protagonist right now this guy
was done NTR in five minutes ago
I'm like I'm like I don't know why I'm
just I'm just this shows I can't keep
watching this I'm done you just you just
see [__] messy like all the top
football players they're just like [__]
they're just schizophrenic you know and
Bobby in the World Cup final he was just
listening to his little monster that was
telling him to goal that's probably wait
until like I just loved it how they were
like the original movies is just like
the two walls inside
you just you zoom into their like
peoples and you just see the [__] uh
like the sketchy eyes they get when
they're listening to their monsters
what's up with that the one thing I did
like is that they were like the reason
we're [__] as a nation is because we're
not selfish all right guys so we need
more selfishness from you guys all right
so can we can we make a center to Harbor
selfishness so when I heard that I was
like bars
yeah
we just guys we're just not selfish
enough let's make a multi-million dollar
facility to make uh kids more selfish uh
so that's what we're gonna do uh that's
all in favor say aye and the only way we
can do that is to pit you all against
each other I don't know I think blue
locks just dumb fun it's it's I'm never
gonna take it seriously oh no I wish I
wish I wish I could look at it like that
but I think I'm just burnt out on Sports
Anime yeah I think uh what's your
favorite sports anime what'd you say not
counting ping pong I don't know I don't
count
so far and Beyond what you're what you
see in your typical Sports Anime yeah
that I don't know I think if I watch
krokino because I watched all of Croco
basket if I watch that now I don't think
I could sit through it I think I sat
through it at a time where that was
appealing to me yeah and I have to
recognize that my anime tastes have
changed and Sports Anime definitely
appeals to that kind of uh Teenage part
of my brain that loves over hyped and
superpowers in real life yeah like I
think
I think as a kid you really like put
yourself in those situations where
you're like hey I wish I could be like
this in sport like I wish I could be the
goat like I wish and I can I can kind of
be like whoa that's [__] sick so yeah
to answer what is my favorite sports
anime it's hard to say because like I
really enjoyed watching croconawasket
but I don't think I can sit through it
now I weirdly enough I like the omushi
pedal but I didn't finish it because
they have so much [__] episodes yeah
I watched like the first two seasons and
I digged it but again I can't think of
any sports anime I kind of liked a lot I
thought free was okay but I kept trying
to be they kept trying to like just get
horny so question is that a Sports Anime
though uh well yeah that is a Sports
Anime it's a horny anime that disguised
itself as Sports yeah that's true your
life is pretty good yeah yeah it was I
thought it was that was a great story
um I'm horrible Sports Anime is that
like you're in it for the long term like
it's always it's always like uh and I
get it because you have to show the
growing yeah I also okay another thing
about blue log that pissed me off I hate
it when they try and make out that I'll
protect Agonist is like the weakest one
there and it's like he's obviously
[__] not like he's like ranked two
299 out of 300. it's like [__] off No
One Believes that we're watching this
it's the my hero formula yeah and I'm
like none of us believe that this guy is
The Shootist here straight up like let's
just be we want them to make a shown in
where they started off like the
protagonist is the shittest one and he
just Remains the shittest one for them
that or like let's just be honest he's
like the 20th out of 300.
and we watch a guy who's already very
talented just work much harder to become
the goat like right why stop setting
stop doing this like it's obvious he's
not the shittest in real life if you're
the shittish you're gonna still be the
[__] see this is this is another
reason why I still think slam dunk is
the goat because what they did with
hanamichi the main character is that
like they built it up at the beginning
is like he's never played basketball
before but he has the physical prowess
to become the greatest basketball yeah
that's cool and seeing that and he
starts off [__] but he's so confident in
himself yeah and so cocky about himself
that when he does does go into a match
and pull off a six slam dunk you're just
like [__] yeah yeah it's yeah I guess my
problem is suspension of disbelief and
how often I have to do it with these
shows yeah it's it like I you know
talking to you it sounds like you in
entertainment your taste of more geared
towards something grounded and something
more yeah I mean you know it's not just
a natural progression yeah not to say
that I wouldn't like obviously if
there's some dumb [__] in chainsaw man
I'm gonna be like oh cool but it's like
okay you know you're talking shocker
you're talking football right where
whatever it is which is rooted in
reality
I would argue that chainsaw man fought
as ridiculous as is feels more grounded
for sure anything in blue look and
that's just because you know I look at
someone explains the rules of the world
yeah I look at some like chainsaw man I
look at something like blue log blue
lock is you know you know when you talk
to someone and you're like oh yeah this
was like really anime you know blue lock
has everything that gives you that
feeling of just like all all of these
anime
bullshit-esque things that we've just
got all gotten used to sure yeah and you
think of so many shows like blue lock
that is just like oh this is just when I
think of what a typical anime is like in
terms of all the tropes and everything
that we kind of uh criticize not
criticize but parody anime to be about
it's all in blue lock when I look at
chainsaw man I see uh something that I
see really grounded and well thought out
characters in a [__] insane world
yeah I mean the most unrealistic thing
about cancer man is how how well that
man is able to function drunk all the
time that's literally the most
unrealistic part that like where I have
to really suspend my disbelief sure I
don't know man if you've seen alcoholic
she's like some people just no that guy
is straight up drinking from The Flash
non-stop ain't no way is
myself
he's so sharp in that show oh is he that
good and they're drunk all the time and
they're coherent he never stumbles once
it's interesting the Sports Anime right
because like I totally get like the
whole like grounded thing because like
you know that's what makes again like I
hate to sound like a broken record
that's what makes shows like slam dunk
so great but on but I feel there's just
as much of an equal enjoyment on the
entire opposite side of the spectrum
yeah where like something like Prince of
Tennis right like that thing is so
[__] unrealistic to the point where
it's just entertaining oh yeah like it's
so stupid where it's like from the
beginning you know you're not going to
take the show the one punch man of
sports like I think the it feels that
Sports Anime haven't changed in like 20
years
like it feels like they've barely
changed and the formula never changes
and then like you know another thing
that pissed me off in blue lock if
you've watched it they introduce this
one character and I don't know why this
annoyed me so much but I just was like
God this is the dumbest [__] they
introduced this character who is like
amazing at football and uh he he plays
overseas in the European leagues he's
like he's a college student he's like I
refuse to play in Japan they're all
peasants and not good enough at the game
and then he overheards this new blue log
Pro he's like I'm listening cancel my
flight I'm staying in Japan I'm like God
this is
so [__] dumb and then it asks you to
take it so seriously like 10 seconds
later yeah like which one like which
which which kind of which what level of
disbelief and what which level of
seriousness do you want me to engage
with this yeah I just don't get it like
yeah um dunk is great for me like that
ball Shield I shoot was great but I
sound like slam dunk's perfect for me
and I should just [__] read it yes
just re-slamed on yeah just re-slamp I
don't know like Sports Anime to me I I
really like just because of how
ridiculous it was with with like it's uh
Battle Royale formats I feel like you
either go one way or the other yeah you
either go this really grounded take like
slam dunk or you go something ridiculous
and just [__] have fun with it yeah
um like a Sports Anime I watched
recently which kind of went like the
ridiculous route uh is an anime called
birdy wink yeah
um and it's a golf anime and I'm like
how the [__] do you make no I I believe
Golf Course how do you how do you how
would you make golf fun to watch yeah
and you and you make it fun to watch by
adding all of the at like every single
anime [__] power you can think of
like this time reversal so so there's uh
so we start off with um this so it's
it's a golf anime but the main character
she says that she's not a golfer she
doesn't play golf all she does is hit a
ball with a stick that's why she does
right so happy Gilman yeah
and and it's basically so what happens
is you taste like Mario you played Mario
Golf yeah of course you take these like
Mario Golf as Aesthetics and power-ups
and stuff like that and then you add it
into a secret underground Society where
you have life or death games yes that
sounds awesome if you're gonna go as far
that far just add depth yeah yeah of
course make that the punishment yeah
yeah because uh with Buddy when there's
this underground Society where people
have like betting games on golf matches
and it's like life or death and someone
has built like us there's like this golf
Seto Kaiba that has built this
underground facility where they can like
reprogram their Golf Course to whatever
like whatever they want and so the
there's there's this golfers come from
all over the world to have life or death
bets on golf matches at this place right
um and then there's just this whole
subplot about the underground
organization you're watching a golf
anime and then some guy just gets like
kamikazeed in the middle of a [__]
road there's like some guy takes off an
RPG and just blows up this guy on the
road I'm like am I watching [__] golf
anime or what but like that's what you
need to make us fun as [__] to watch go
watch bloody Wing that's that's actually
like a really underrated uh Sportster is
there like a pegasus type character that
can see like the exact place there like
he needs to like [__] like everyone
has like some [__] [__] yeah I
love that what's the other anime that
you watching uh so I saw this clip on
Twitter and I've seen it a few times of
this one show and I've been meaning to
watch it because I was just like [__] it
I really want to see the context behind
this goddamn clip
um so I watched a show called uh Golden
Boy oh yeah
I was like that sounds really dumb and
really funny I want to watch it yeah um
I saw it I've seen the balls seen before
and I've seen the bike scene yeah oh
yeah and you've probably seen these
floating around the internet if you've
been around long enough there's a scene
that's quite popular that I feel like it
does the rounds every every few months
where a guy is like dead serious and
then it looks like a serious swimming
competition does happen then he jumps in
and goes
10 seconds and then there's another
scene that always pops up you might have
seen where a dude is like cycling on
electrical wires yeah and then jumps off
a clip it's like the most insane [__]
and I watched it and I was like God this
is such a good show on ironically oh no
no it is good and so horny
I think I think part of the reason it's
so good is the dubs [__] amazing I
think it's so funnily bad yeah the main
guy is screaming dreaming constant yeah
it's I I think the main I'm not sure if
this is true but I think I heard the
main that's this is like the main guy's
only voice acting role and I believe it
because it's it seems like it doesn't
sound like you he's come from a
traditional voice acting background
literally
I feel like it's just because anime's
very expressive I think they took that
as like oh my God it's like literally
anything happens and he just starts
screaming and it's so funny yeah it's so
good it's so chaotic but the voice
setting is just good enough to make it
funny when it's bad yeah because because
he's like John explained the plot as
well I can't remember the plot yeah I
guess I just watched it yeah essential
essentially it's about this guy who's
traveling across Japan and he's quite
intelligent but also really dumb at the
same time and very perverted obviously
yeah and every single episode kind of
centers around a very attractive woman
so he starts and there's always an
attractive woman and they straight up
just show titty a lot in this thing yeah
man it was a different time it's it's
it's there's as a scene with a girl and
a motorcycle and uh this girl just nuts
to on a motorcycle yeah just in the
front of this guy at a gas station she's
like a very attractive I would Describe
MILF
um and she just nuts from the vibration
of the engine yeah and then it proceeds
to get like there's proceeds to be a
downhill race where he beats a
motorcycle and he's and he just jumps
off cliffs it's the most insane [__] and
it's so funny it's so good and the whole
show is uh how he goes to these new jobs
and these people don't like him but then
he proves to be really good and
resourceful even though he's a massive
pervert and it's just fun it's like 30
minute episodes that all unfortunately
only six episodes six episodes but also
they were all they used six 10 out of 10
episodes oh dude I was laughing crying
at so many points it's so funny it's so
good the animation is actually amazing
oh yeah it looks insane so looks amazing
there's so many scenes in there just I I
remember so many [__] scenes in there
just some I think of the voice acting
plays a massive part as well because you
never know what to expect oh yeah right
we're no no we we've had enough kind of
my expectations so many times yeah we've
heard enough like anime voice types
would be to be like okay in a comedy
anime this is where the punch line is or
this is what it's going to sound like in
XXX
um and in Golden Boy there would just be
like this random line that he speaks in
the most like out of context it feels
like half the lines definitely were just
added in and definitely weren't there in
the original yeah yeah so weird and so
fun
um but the characters really likable
even though he does like a bunch of
weird stuff that normally you'd be like
every episode he uh all the women here
at some point for some reason is
cleaning their toilets and every single
episode he starts like kissing the
toilets and then of course the woman
always walks in yeah and it's just
always it's always just weird how it all
kind of plays in it's all very like
perfect it's like if Mr Bean was a
massive pervert Yeah and could talk in
the end I don't mind those kinds of
seats like so fun it was so good if
you're gonna make a character like
degenerate go 100 oh yeah because if you
make them just a little bit degenerate
you like because they're so degenerate
where you suspend disbelief you suspend
disbelief to be like they say in a real
person if you just add like a little bit
of it then sometimes just like man what
why you gotta be so why you gotta be
like that it becomes awkward [__]
melioda smell like [__] it up like you
you must you are so [__] close you
know and then you just had this one
little thing and you're like why did
that need to be there yeah so if you're
gonna make someone degenerate just like
go 100 like 110 yeah um and that's what
they did with Golden Boy so good it's so
[__] horny but it's horny to the
point where you just don't take it
seriously and it just adds to that humor
it's such a good show it is it's very
good so worth the watch it is
humor to like the like to done to like
the finest degree it's like humor and
then they just show you literally like
the sexiest shot ever in anime like it's
so horny yeah and it's so well done it's
insane it got me thinking I was like
damn and every woman in it is like a
MILF and I was like damn where did we go
wrong with anime like in the 90s they
were just it was all about MILFs sounds
like back of the good old days I
genuinely I've never said it before I
was born in the wrong generation
they had it they had it right back then
and now it's all [__] you gotta watch
more 90 shows everyone's like a 12 year
old 200 vampire you know it's like what
is this [__] where are the 90s officers
the 90s of year era man they had
something
wild things women who are hot and work
in offices uh who uh Stern and want to
beat you up and I'm like that's what we
need back I don't want these Lolly
vampire women I don't want them get rid
of them I want them I want these office
workers back
good honestly like it's because here's a
is here's the thing about something like
Golden Boy I find it so rare to find a
comedy anime that actually makes me like
laugh oh yeah it's like so good it's I
can count on like one hand the amount of
comedy anime I think are actually like
gut bustingly like funny yeah and Golden
Boy is one of those shows definitely
because I feel like anime anime comedy a
lot of the times I find like really like
slapstick but it's I I rarely find it
like haha funny it's just like oh you
know I think it's I think the one for me
obviously comedy is subjective but I
think the ones for me are just like the
more absurdist comedy yeah like the ones
where it's just like like Golden Boy
right where it's like you can't you
don't know what's happening next yeah
and it's that like subversion of
expectation to like the most ridiculous
conclusion that makes it really like
that's why like you know like I find
shows like nichijo and ginto are really
funny because it's like it does that
exact same thing of like you think the
joke's going one way and it's like nope
we're just gonna go complete 180 and
just show you the most ridiculous [__]
right yeah and I feel a lot of like
comedy anime especially nowadays really
struggled to do that because I don't
know maybe because like they're afraid
of like alienating Their audience I
don't know I think they've always
struggled to do that comedy anime are
like really [__] hard to find a lot
of times because a lot of times the joke
is oh trip on your panties oh look at me
oh I walk into you when you're showering
yeah yeah oh no please oh don't hit me
no and I'm just like oh okay okay all
right okay like I said if you're gonna
go that direction like one comedy anime
or one comedy manga that has made me
laugh out loud is like prison school
back in the day where yeah it's just a
bunch it's the most DJing [__] holy [__]
it is the definition of boys will be
boys but
but like my grand blue as well as
another reason oh yeah ground blue it
was the most like last night yes
so funny yeah it is the most yeah that
is the most like lad energy yeah it's
one of the few manga I've ever read uh
that reminds me of an old school you
know college comedy film remember those
back in the day when we had like [__]
Americans like the American Pie yeah
super bad and that kind of thing but
it's like seeing that kind of humor
translated in a Japanese lens I thought
it was like really [__] interesting
and it's one of the funniest things that
one of the funniest manga I think I've
read yeah uh definitely both prison
school and ground blue uh just like it's
really really hard to make me laugh out
loud yeah so those definitely did that
for sure today's episode is sponsored by
Honey the easy way to save When shopping
on your iPhone or Computer Boys how do
you feel when you find a deal on the
best extremely excited doesn't it suck
that you don't have a coupon code
sometimes you know you wanna
well just for you guys Honey's here to
save you honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best ones it finds to
your cart but how does it work I hear
you wondering audience well imagine
you're shopping on one of your favorite
websites when you're at the checkout the
honey button appears and all you have to
do is Click apply Cooper that's all okay
so wait a few seconds is honey search
for coupons I can find for that site and
if honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop so Joey how much
did you save using honey well you know
we went to Thailand for God's wedding
and uh flights are getting kind of
expensive right now hey man thankfully
thanks to honey I saved over a hundred
dollars on my flight to thanks honey for
making my wedding happen with the boys
honey doesn't just work on desktops
though boys it works on your iPhone too
just activated on Safari on your phone
and save on the go if you don't already
have honey you could be straight up
missing out on savings guys and by
getting it you're doing yourself a solid
and helping us as well so get PayPal
honey for free at joinhoney.com trash
taste that's joinhoney.com trash taste
back to the episode but yeah in terms of
what I've been watching well I I
actually want to besides everything
that's why besides everything because
it's like end of the year and this is
like the time I have to watch everything
I guess I had like some I was thinking
what would I recommend to you boys since
I assumed you guys were not were not
watching anime
well not as much as you and what is it
that you could possibly miss you know
right I mean the golf one sounds right
up my alley okay no I I go I got one for
you Joey I got one for you I'm listening
all right you've probably heard of this
before
um but it's not it's not mainstream yeah
it's not it's not mainstream yet that's
good that's a good start
um Bocce The Rock I'm like what do you
mean that's [__] everywhere is it
everywhere everyone just annoying me
about it to be fair I have started
watching you you wouldn't like that
corner I know I I sure it's so good
though I'm like guys I just you don't
want me to watch it because I'm gonna
[__] on it don't ask me don't ask me to
save it save washing the Rock from
Connor you don't want me to watch this
because I'm not gonna react the way you
want me to like I'm gonna probably hate
it because it's yeah it's fun and you
like it but I'm like I just know I'm not
gonna like that yeah yeah I mean you can
watch it for bands if you want but like
I'm telling you you're not gonna like it
yeah but I almost want you to watch it
just to hear what just to hear your
opinion just the shield
uh yeah but yes to be fair I have
started watching oh yeah yeah I'm a
couple of episodes in yeah yeah I mean
it's like you know what you're not the
only one who was like you would love
this show Joey like literally everyone
has been like yeah you would like this
you would because you like chaon right
yeah and I love this is like better
chaon yes I [__] said it okay I'm
gonna start a war right now
it could have been as bad as bang dream
it's all right yeah it's it's literally
like you know I can see why people like
hey on I personally didn't like hey on
um but it's everything that I wanted K
on to be yeah you know because it has
this mix of you know cute girls doing
cute things stuff but then they're
actually they actually like trying to
get [__] done and I'm like okay now I
can get behind I think I think the word
you're looking for is they actually have
a personality
because let's be real as much as I love
Kion not really like a an Eclectic cast
of characters you know where it's like
oh wow she's this girl and she's this
goal it's like it's very surface level
with K1 but I mean obviously Kion never
took itself seriously in that respect so
it's fine yeah but like yeah no I I
totally agree like I've only a couple of
episodes in obviously some preserving
like full judgment on it but yeah
already I can see like yeah I can see
why a lot of people say like this is
like the better chaon yeah or I guess
not the I guess the deeper K on is it's
it's it's it's different yeah I was just
like I just left a [__] on Care on fans
but it's not really the same show aside
from the fact that it's cute girls
making a band but I mean there's been
this recent Trend in anime that I don't
like I haven't really been able to get
behind and it's because I call it like
she just like me for real shows where
it's um it's just this show where this
cute girl is just like socially awkward
oh here we go again you're talking about
water motor I'm talking about water mode
[__] Comey song
um
not nagatora actually I'm sure there
were some girls or some guys oh yeah
just like me for real yeah but just
these socially awkward anime characters
and it's just like oh look at me look at
me guys I'm so cute because I can't talk
to people look at me I hate it so much
but like one thing that surprised me
about Bocce the rock is that it totally
goes down that route but they convey
moments using animation that
like that you relate with on like a
[__] it hits you in your soul how
much it hurts sometimes like seeing her
go through these different situations is
the same kind of situation that are
portrayed in these other shows but they
go so off the walls with like that
animation that it just it it turns it
into almost like a meme which is why I
think Bocce The Rock has been so
widespread on like Twitter so many
reaction here because the entire show is
just a living meme because there's so
many like there's so many moments where
it's so relatable that it just becomes
in it just becomes a meme in and of
itself no and and I think that's you
know another huge reason why like you
know when when Co when commission was
airing right like yeah why you saw so
many [__] reaction images for of like
Comey son right because it's like yeah
as you said it's it's like it's just
like me for real right and it's like
they purposely they purposely make the
faces of the characters reacting in
certain ways to be so memorable in like
the reader or the watch is mine yeah
it's just like it's just like yep
immediately you have to like you know
like another one one of those shows that
I just couldn't [__] stand when it
was airing was like umarishan right like
oh my God I know I hate to I hate to
bring this up again yeah and I hate
beating a dead horse but like Mario
channel was like another show where it
was like so many people watching Mario
channel was just like oh she played
video game and she doesn't work she's
just like me for real dog this is why I
like Golden Boy because he likes MILFs
and he Cycles everything and that's why
I was like
he's just like me
for real 25 years old close enough and
he likes MILFs and he wants to cycle of
it and he just Cycles around people I'm
just like damn he just like me for real
yeah I I just I don't know what it is
that I've realized now I was like for
the longest time I wondered like why
haven't I watched nichijo and I was like
I think I just don't want to watch
schoolgirls yeah I just don't care to
watch girls in school yeah I'm just kind
of like I don't know if I this if that's
me like I'm a Google Chat mindset don't
wanna I'm like I just I just don't I
don't know why I think think Nishi Joe
is an exception because yes you know
some of the characters are school girls
and a lot of the jokes are based in the
school yeah but the jokes are so
incredibly absurd to the point where it
doesn't matter I know that's why I want
to watch it yeah but I think other shows
like chemical community and all those
type of shows I'm just like I don't
think I care no no no I actually agree I
just why Bocce like that was my biggest
surprise of the year because I came into
it being like I'm gonna hate this but
I'm watching this because this is my job
and I watched it because I I watched it
because you know I was making my end of
year video and I'm like [__] this is
actually really good I relate to this on
a level that I did not like that I did
not think and I remember I was like is
it is it is it a me thing I mean am I am
I like is it just is is it just
something weird or is it is this show
actually good so I convinced Sydney to
watch it with me as well and there were
literally some scenes where uh we were
we would be watching it together and
Sydney like literally just like it just
goes oh oh like that you know the the
very Sydney way to do a very normal
reaction
almost in the reaction and uh I go
Sydney what what's going on she's like
[__] I hate it I hate it I get out of my
mind get out of my mind because we've
there'd be several scenes where she you
know but she does something cringe and
this would that like that would just
unlock a core memory that Sydney had
just buried away doing cringe things
that she forgotten about and like
watching that show unlocks like 10
different core memories per episode uh
which is I think the real magic of bocce
where it just it takes these moments and
if you've ever been a cringed teenager
in your life which a lot of us have uh
including me
um there will be something in there that
you will just make you remember
something shitty why do you want to
relive that huh why would you want to
relive being cringe ah oh no it's just
uh I don't know why you want every I
don't know why you'd want to relive that
but it's just you know it's just
something that you relate to I guess I
think I think what I respect about botch
of the rock so far is like you know what
like yes you know the cringe elements
are obviously like you know very you
know hashtag relatable but I think how
they portray those certain scenes is one
like probably some of the most realistic
like representations of like real life
situations that have happened to people
and I feel like they do it in like a
tasteful way where it's like also funny
where because like that's one of the
huge reasons why I couldn't [__]
stand Watton right because it's like
they took the cringe aspect to such a
degree where it was just like a just
unrealistic yeah and B it was just like
painful to watch like there was no like
there was nothing that I could like
watch in a particular water mode I see
where I'm like like there was none of
that right but whereas with Bocce they
do it in like a comedic way but also in
a very realistic yeah I love it like
whenever whenever like something cringe
happens she just like goes she goes low
res and she goes deviantART like yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm like [__] man I feel
that like I feel that that is so much
more of like a realistic like
representation of how you would feel in
a situation right like that right
whereas in watamote like what does she
do she just [__] shits her pants and
goes home right like it's it's not it's
not fun to watch I I like that show she
just [__] so fast yeah like it's not
funny yeah I like that show because it
was a real good indication of which
people to ignore online yeah like
everyone who had a watermote uh profile
picture you straight up ignore them yeah
exactly sure
um yeah this is this is one scene I know
you guys gonna tell us who that has
happened like many many times just to
like paying an example of like something
okay so they're out you know they're out
as a group of mates um and they're
trying to take a picture for their bands
um and every time they try to take a
picture Bocce just has the worst [__]
stupidest face in every picture that
they take and I'm like she's just like
me for real
and I'm like oh that's a word that's
never happened to me what why are you
why are you doing this to me Bocce why
are you [__] doing this to me and
then the girl's like oh we should post
this online and boji just has like a
mental breakdown and I'm like I've never
had a mental breakdown but like
internally I'm like Joey are you [__]
posting this online God I have an entire
like catalog of photos of me and God
where God just has like how did you pull
that face off in a split second just
like add like out of context gone faces
are just a thing not just on trash taste
subreddit but just in our life and it's
always been that she's been that's just
been my [__] life how you relate to
it
um I realized I watched another show
before you recommend okay before I
forget I'm gonna forget yeah finished
mob psycho three ah oh yeah
how was it Peak hmm I like mob psycho a
lot but I it was kind of confusing a
little bit seeing how they handled the
third season I so I I watched season two
amazing yeah and I I remember when it
ended I was like is there gonna be
another season and I saw a discussion
online that there wasn't that much left
in the manga to adapt yeah yeah um so
they it's kind of odd it felt very uh
separated yeah uh I haven't I haven't
started watching it yet okay yeah so I
had I mean I had kind of like a similar
opinion uh when mob psycho season three
got announced I remember thinking where
can they take the story yeah all the
Loose Ends have been tied up uh I'm not
sure if they can do anything uh if they
can add any big plot elements yeah that
uh are better than what they showed in
season two right because I think season
two was a pretty complete season you
know everyone they could have stopped
there and I wouldn't have really yeah
much about it exactly everyone had their
character arcs and everything like that
and then watching season three
um it felt kind of like a season-long
epilogue yeah yeah for sure it felt like
the continuation where it's like hey if
you want complete closure to all of
these characters yeah this is it yeah uh
but it didn't feel necessary like it
like it's it isn't it weird how like I
felt like these characters stories were
being wrapped up completely but I felt
like okay if you don't really care that
much about seeing it all wrap up I think
you can probably skip season three and
you'll be fine I mean I I still I still
think it's necessary I think uh my thing
about season three is that it felt it it
felt like it did an E12 episodes you
know it felt like dude that's my yeah
for sure yeah it was like one or two
episodes where I was like come on yeah
yeah let's get through it yeah like it
definitely felt like oh they are really
patting this out because they need to
make an entire season out of this and I
don't think there's an entire season's
worth of the content that needed to be
like I think nine or eight episodes
would have been yeah pretty perfect
pretty perfect the way it's mop season
at three I mean I guess like spoilers
the first six episodes are its own arc
there's like two episodes no two or
three episodes two or three episodes and
then there's a two or three then there's
a three episode finale yeah it kind of
wraps it all up and yeah I mean the the
six part thing and the start felt way
too long that felt that that needed to
be like three four
genuinely yeah yeah like that was too
much and then the last one was pretty
good but also drag it all felt just long
it all felt bogged down yeah um some
important things happened that I thought
were really good
um Cash Ball did you chill do you care
no I want to watch it yeah
one big thing happens in it where I felt
like oh yeah that kind of needed to
happen yeah I'm sure you can think the
ending yeah the ending yeah okay that
makes more sense yeah it happened when
you said you didn't feel necessary I
actually like that was the one thing
that felt necessary yeah exactly like I
felt like oh okay what now that I've
finished mobs three I'm like okay I was
wrong I do think it was necessary I
think it was necessary just because
season three is it ended mob in the most
perfect way possible and I think you
cannot kind of like underestimate the
importance of a good [__] ending
basically where everything is wrapped up
everything is happy and just I'm seeing
that final frame
um well I just it just like
put everything together and just and
just like was able to make me be like
okay mob's over it's a [__] amazing
show from beginning to end uh did it
have its fault in like the pacing and
stuff like that maybe in some places
um I still think season two was is
absolutely MOB season two is just
tightly written some of the most amazing
fight scenes in all of anime and it's
just Banger every single episode season
three felt a little stretched out but I
still think what season three did was
absolutely necessary I think the ending
was necessary but I think again yeah
like I said just Pat it to get rid of
the padding yeah cut it down make it
quicker yeah like there's this fight in
this middle of season three right and
it's [__] insane it's it's absolutely
[__] insane but I wasn't as invested
in that fight as the fights in like
season two for example so it was very
confusing following that fight and the
the you know the fight yeah in season
three the one that happened I was like
wait what it was really confusing I
don't know if I'm dumb yeah yeah it
seems to be an occurring problem with
you where it's like I'm having trouble
following these spices that's manga
manga I have trouble following fight
scenes uh in the anime I was like what
but yeah I mean it was good I like the
ending a lot I think the ending helped
um just yeah cut it down so if you're
gonna watch season three be prepared
that it's gonna it's gonna feel like
it's really [__] slow at some points
but the ending is worth it all right
time speed got it I would say
yeah I wouldn't say that I just you know
I I do think now that mob's over it's
going to go down as a modern classic now
that it's like over over it's it's
[__] incredible and I think season
three was less actiony and it had played
more on like the characterizing which I
think was the biggest surprise of season
two right because I remember watching
season one on Mob psycho and I was just
like oh this is like one punch man but
like his younger brother right yeah
that's what I felt right yeah we're just
like oh look at all these flashy fights
oh this is all cool and then season two
happened and then you actually see that
there there is like so much thought put
into the character I'm so scared it's
not my favorite shows like ever yeah I
really like it a lot yeah and I and I
think like even though it's just ended
season three has just ended I think it's
gonna go down as like one of like one of
the best anime ever made because it's
this is this is the kind of adaptations
other manga [__] dream of one is a
complete adaptation and two two bones
did not drop the ball at all yeah in any
in any part of the adaptation you know
it was just some of the most incredible
animation we've seen in the medium of
anime yeah
um still the best looking I don't know
how they made psychic fights look good
but they look really good you just
wouldn't think that psychic fights look
I went to go mode yeah they go decomo
yeah like that that fight in the in
season two with the teleporting I still
I still remember that foreign
[Laughter]
one thing I will say uh without spoiling
what happens
um I'm glad that there was a moment
where they played the opening song once
again yes
you know
animal anime needs to bring this back I
just did anime just like talking about
anime tropes that we got tired of I
don't know why anime decided that that
was just a Cheesy thing that they should
just stop doing because I I noticed
modern and like more modern animals now
more modern anime have just stopped
putting that opening in the climax a
moment and I'm like why did we stop
doing this yeah this is [__] epic I
remember this like seeing seeing mob
three and hearing it I'm just like it's
been so [__] long why do we like when
I when that song came on I was like I
feel like I'm gonna [__] cry but
let's go oh [__] cool man put your
Banger it's such a banger as well and
it's just I don't know why anime decided
to stop doing this like if they thought
it was like oh we're better than this
now we don't need to put the openings
yeah we can just use uh we can use use
like one of the tracks from the OST I'm
like no put the [__] opening back
yeah we use a random unit
solidified in my mind that Reagan is
like one of my favorite characters in
anime like bro he's such a goat yeah he
is yes I wanted to lie to me just just
[__] con my life dude give me a give
me just come on me and just give me
friendship and then become a genuine
part of my life yeah I I would happily
be conned
Reagan for sure
imagine like telling your mates that you
were [__] you will not believe who
just came he was stabbed my Reagan holy
[__] [__]
so what's the anime you're gonna
recommend to me then gone let's see oh
miss it's hard because I think you've
seen most of the anime
um most most of the anime that I would
recommend I was gonna say something like
mob but you've watched mob
um if I had to throw like a curveball
like a lesser known one a lesser known
one if I just throw a curveball it would
either be
probably
you liked re-zero right yeah probably
summertime render see I I wanted to
watch it because it looked good and so
of course I it's on Netflix in Japan I
was like great I'm gonna watch it oh no
subtitles oh yeah is it not on is it on
Netflix in Japan
there's no English subtitles okay
Netflix does this for some reason uh
they they region lock stuff in Japan I'm
guessing it's an agreement with the
content yeah whoever gives them the
content that they can't have English
subtitles otherwise good way to practice
Japanese I mean well it is good but then
when it's a mind [__] show you're like
oh oh no I watched I watched jujuticus
in the movie is in the cinema yeah
that's fine I watched the odd taxi in
the cinema that was not fine that was
definitely not kind I did not know what
was happening yeah luckily I'd watched
the entire show so I understood what was
happening right right but if I dude it
was impossible trying to figure out what
they were saying yeah I I have a rule
because I do watch approximately 50 of
my anime without subtitles on okay like
boccio watch without subtitles on my
rule is is it set in high school if the
answer is yes I watch it without the
problem
is it about high school am I gonna watch
it probably not like it needs to be
really compelling yeah and then there's
other like flow charts in my head that
I'm like is it also an isakai definitely
normal because I just I every Sky show
is garbage change my mind uh yeah you're
right there are two I know you like that
that can't be an argument because fans
already know that I know I know but
that's the problem and so what I'm when
I'm ruling out all ishakai and all high
school anime I'm literally left with
like two a season yeah
95 of it I did a stream yesterday going
through like a list of uh this random
guys list of like the top isekai of all
time yeah and I have like my rule of uh
if something is what I would call a good
isekai right is it's it's a show that I
could recommend to someone who is not
interested in East Chicago yeah like
I'll watch this yeah like I'll watch it
right yeah but I think it needs to be
good and um I came down to the
conclusion that uh there are only two
modern shows that fall into that
category one of one is three zero the
other is mashoku tensei
watch both of them
and I'm like I was going uh I was going
down the list of everything else I was
like
skip I'm like I don't know like people
were like honestly with a cold and soup
I was like
that's like just barely was like a 50 50
for me yeah in terms of like if you
don't like isekai it's like the Napoleon
Dynamite of anime yeah like connoisseur
is like yeah you need to be really
integrated into anime culture to like it
because there's no way you can just
recommend connoisseur to like a random
person yeah also season two was not that
strong in my opinion if you recommend
connoisseur to someone who hasn't
watched anime yeah they don't think
you're a free yeah same with like No
Game No Life as well you know
that's the [__] you don't want to
recommend a really good show please
ignore yeah
the Lolly and stuff like that
um
it's great yeah yeah
um yeah summertime render I think is the
other really overlooked anime I've seen
a couple of episodes of that yeah again
I did want to watch it it looks sick
yeah it's not on Netflix it's on Disney
plus though it's a Disney it's on
Netflix though and that's why I think it
must be it must be in Japan it's
definitely an I I thought it would be a
Disney plus exclusive at least it has
English subtitles with Disney plus uh
because For the Longest Time Disney kind
of like locked it away and was like no
rest of the world you can't watch
summertime render [__] JoJo all over
again that's why no one [__] talked
about it but yeah it's like re-zero uh
it's I was trying to think of something
witty but it's just like it's just
[__] re-zero it's all set in summer
that's basically it oh I'll go with that
and it's uh but it's hot
basically basically re-zero and
higarashi but he hasn't watching garage
oh you have okay I watched the dubbed we
had a conversation oh yeah that's all
right I watched the dubbed and that was
a mistake we [__] did you literally
watched one of the worst times
yeah
when when is there another season coming
what's up with that uh oh I don't know I
mean it should take it so long I mean
nagatsuki is still riding it oh how many
REM figures do we have to move before
they they like surely the the re-zero
money pool must be infinite
like with the amount of REM figures
they've sold
um yeah but nagatsuki doesn't see barely
any of that [__] yeah well that's true
but anyway I thought I thought that was
already there's already enough material
yeah no there is there is
uh what's the hold up I don't know man
hopefully it doesn't turn into a [__]
No Game No Life we is right like in it
it only feels like this happened to
Japan where there could be like an
insane amount of demand for something
and just they just don't do it yeah
dude if we had a re-zero in America dude
we would have 19 spin-offs yes yeah how
how Subaru got circumcised I'm just I'm
just playing [__] story I'm just
praying they don't pull a No Game No
Life and give us a movie instead of a
season two I don't know some sometimes
sometimes Japan go for that [__]
Direction yeah like I don't but it's
always the shows that like weren't
really that popular right like it's
always the shows you like why it's like
spicy wolf fans my first time it's like
how many [__] seasons of data live is
there now and I'm like who's still
watching that show someone is Young
the [__] these people are who are making
Idol shows can someone get them over to
like the good shows because do those
dudes know how to get shows mate like
straight up they get shows mate no I
I'll tell you the difference I'll tell
you the [__] difference okay tell me
the [__] difference okay we lied to
clown on Idol fans and everything right
they spend their [__] money okay
sorry have we not spent enough money on
re-zero [__] how many REM there's a rem
every second in Japan a rem figure is
sold if not 10. well okay like you go on
Twitter and you see all of these Twitter
accounts complaining about like oh CG in
anime and like chainsaw man look like
this do you think they [__] paid for
that show [__] I guaranteed most of them
didn't even pay for anything I I have
not bought ten thousand dollar worth of
uh you know changing my merge I bought
at least like two grand worth of rams
yeah you know
and I know my uh my other fellow uh
people who live here have yeah uh you
know every day when I whenever I go to
the crane game place I always see people
winning Rams you know the ram fund must
be deep why
as well like I just don't understand
like it doesn't make sense I'm just
saying Idol fans [__] turn up man oh
my God
for that [__] okay yeah I don't know
yeah that's I I I I honestly do I'm I'm
gonna make a prediction that they are
making more re-zero it just takes a long
[__] time to make anime
um I'm not appreciating it enough yeah
yeah I think one of the big issues right
now is just like every Anime Studio is
just Ram hooked up to capacity over
Cabana I'm gonna be sad if I'm like 40
when re-zero ends or some [__] what the
[__] what is this that one piece
I mean I'm reading that right now it's
hard to do anything else when you read
one piece I'm not talking about it I
don't want to talk I I want to just wait
till I'm done but yeah it is it takes oh
yeah it does it's short but I don't know
that's I've we have we have so many
shows coming out right now that
sometimes I'm just like okay I show just
gonna if a show takes 10 years to finish
if I could get through Evangelion then I
can get through anything you know if I
could wait well all of this time you say
that but I think like movies like Avatar
the weight like actually it was a
massive detriment I think to me caring
about anything
um well yes because just people have
shorter attention no I I don't I don't
think that the time period made a
difference if I've seen avatarity by the
way let's see how you're watching out
here yeah yeah I I have an opinion on
this with three hero when I watched the
new season last time it didn't mean to
be like all right yeah why do I give a
[__] again okay yeah yeah it's it's it
can be frustrating and I think that's
what um I know anime just takes a while
right like Overlord I just I just I just
haven't watched the new season because
I'm like it's not worth it I know I have
watched the new season like really yeah
I watched three seasons of Overlord
right and I loved I loved every every
season I watched but the thought of
having to remind myself to give a [__]
again about everything is like okay I
just I did I can't yeah and I know
because overlord's a lot Overlord is
yeah like it's very like dense in its
world and characters
um yeah I mean but it just makes it that
much harder to get back into it right
yeah you have to remind yourself again
about all those little details yeah yeah
for me for me it's like playing a jrpg
quitting halfway through that wanting to
play it again and getting back to the
game possible I don't remember anything
impossible
at least for the Avatar it was like it
was basically like very easy kids story
plot line yeah whereas stuff like
Overlord and re-zero feels like a lot to
get back into and so that's basically
why I didn't watch Overlord the new one
and I think I will I don't think I care
anymore
yeah that too like I was just like I was
just like I don't want to sit through
once again I think it shows just hold it
just take way too long to continue like
what was the break between the overlord
seasons was it like three years two
years just three years two years three
years is too much I think I don't know I
I I feel like it could happen
um if
honestly 12 episodes it's too much
honestly because the example I use right
the example I use attacking Titan yeah
right between season one and season two
we had like a [__] five six year
break or something like that yeah it was
it was a long break and most of the
everyone thought that by the Time season
two came out everyone would stop giving
a [__] about attack ones everyone's kind
of did though everyone kind of did for a
while for like a little bit but I felt
like it wasn't until season three where
everyone started carrying again but then
you only really start caring when the
hype [__] starts happening yeah yeah
because the problem with something like
re-zero season two is that it was it
felt more like a setup season for sure
for sure and like you're like I don't
really care what's going on and I don't
really care to invest myself because
there's not really anything hype
happening but let's say re-zero season
three does happen I don't know what
happens further on and there are some
[__] Banger moments there are some
hype [__] happening you're gonna start
like oh [__] I wanna I wanna like care
about this again you know and I I feel
like something dense like overlords my
big problem with Overlord in general
right now after watching season 4 is
that every season I'm I come in with the
same thing when I'm like oh I really
like the world and the characters and
waiting for like I wait for that oh [__]
moment because it always feels like it's
building that oh [__] moment and then it
just doesn't deliver the same way I want
it to deliver 12 episodes just isn't
enough for stuff like Overlord I think I
think it's too the the overlord world is
so dense like you said that 12 episodes
just feels like you got like an itch of
an arc yeah it feels like you didn't get
anything yeah
um whereas when you compare it to like
let's say other like normal like live
action stuff in America it's like okay
well they might do 10 episodes but like
they're an hour long so you really get
into some [__] I I think
just not like six what is 12 hours is
that like five hours of content four
hours of content 12 episodes yeah that's
like four hours it's about four and a
half yeah yeah
like four hours of content isn't that
much isn't that much for a really big
World building show like Overlord yeah
where they they've hinted so much stuff
and it's like man it's like I can't even
in season three I was like wait who's
who's who again yeah and you hinted at
this a little bit in season one I'm like
what yeah I'm It's just tough to care it
is it is I want to I really want to care
I like I like Overlord I like the world
it was sick yeah yeah yeah because it's
yeah it's it's it's a really sick world
and there's a lot going on which is like
like I said something that I always
liked about overlords and it's always
felt like it built up towards something
yeah and then when yeah it just you know
it's good when there's like multiple
channels uploading lore videos about
Overlord yeah and there's so many of
them and they're good and you're like
well this is actually [__]
interesting yeah which honestly
sometimes if I just need a recap I'll
just like watch a recap yeah it's good
it's good yeah that's that's normally
enough for me because normally what I
find a lot of the times with big open
worlds like this is that for like the
important story beats 90 of the
information isn't isn't like necessarily
necessary it's necessary if you really
really want to immerse yourself in the
world before like the core basic story
beats of this epic thing is happening
what do I need to know going into this
beforehand you can normally like you
know just you know read a [__] Wiki
uh well yeah to get up to date that
makes you just think about like Game of
Thrones where it's like yeah you can
have the service level plot points yeah
enjoy it or you can really get in the
world building and get [__] lost in
how good the world is exactly how that
will interact yeah and I feel like that
it's just hard to do that with a lot of
anime yeah bro I'd rather I I'd rather
die and lose both my arms than read a
visual novel I'm just not I'm not I mean
yeah I'm not doing it yeah I can't I
can't read a visual knowledge yeah I can
only imagine the writing yeah oh my God
one one other anime I want to talk about
about which I think is being holy [__]
so underappreciated right now is
a new Gundam oh okay the new it's uh
it's weird seeing just the dichotomy
between how popular and how well
advertised it is here in Japan yeah and
just how under watched it is with like
Western audiences you go to like people
are scared of Gundam yeah you go to like
the my anime list page and you scroll
Downs of like all of like the fall anime
seasons and Gundams like right near the
bottom I'm like how the [__] is a show
this good that's delivering this hard
that close to the bottom in terms like
popularity yeah it's it's weird right
because like I think for a lot of people
Gundam is just like this thing that's
been around for [__] you know yeah
almost half a century at this point
right it's super intimidating it's
intimidating because like people know
the name yeah but so few have actually
sat down and like even watched half of
the [__] that's come out of the Gundam
Universe yeah yeah and so like when you
see a new Gundam immediately you just
think oh well I do want to watch it it
looks cool but that would mean I have to
go all the way back and watch everything
and obviously you don't have to right
you don't have to no absolutely
it's kind of like so there's I'm gonna
sound like that person again uh so
there's like separates there's like
several different timelines in Gundam
and so there's one main timeline that's
kind of like the MCU where it goes all
the way yeah kind of except things are
in chronological order right yeah yeah
um yeah so we go and that timeline goes
all the way to the very very first
Gundam that was made in like 1970 or
something and I I haven't watched any of
those Gundams because I'm that guy who
wants to really immerse myself and know
every little Easter egg and stuff like
that so in order for me to enjoy some
some Gundams like for example Gundam
unicorn or
um you know Thunderball Gundam Hathaway
uh I would need to go all the way back
to the beginning to
gets the full appreciation of everything
going on you don't need to like I'm not
saying you need to this is a me thing
you know I've been trying for years like
hiding myself to be like all right this
is the day yeah where I start my Gundam
journey and then when I look at the list
I'm just like maybe next week yeah
exactly and then there are certain other
Gundams that are just separate from this
main timeline which are much more let's
say newbie friendly stuff like Gundam
Wing Gundam Double O uh what was the
desert Gundam [__] not seed
um I call it Gundam space Africa because
that's basically what it is
do you know what I'm talking about you
[__] know what I'm gonna explain
space Africa to me
oh [__] this is this is this is gonna
it's it's space Africa space Africa
Gundam original shows uh because it was
the last newbie friendly Gundam it's
like you can tell me that I don't need
to watch any of the Gundam but something
in my brain just will not allow me to
watch it and not be like I have I I I
this there's more yeah what's the last
gun you watched that's why you've
mentioned this before I haven't watched
anything
yeah I watched like one episode of that
and then I got scared and I was like no
I'm watching anymore
uh I'm I was like it's not I'm blood at
all for us
yeah okay it's scary all right let me
sell you on like the new gun which is
Gundam the witch from Mercury
um so it's a new Gundam so it's like you
you know I want interaction with this
with the show at least when I've heard
of it the last time I ever heard
anything about it was when we were in
the car to film with uh Charlie right
was critical the guy who picked us up
was talking about it yeah oh yeah that's
right I just remember sitting there and
he's like yeah it's really well actually
that's not what he sounds like this but
he's like because it's just cool they
have like uh lesbians in this one and I
was like what yeah what oh yeah the main
girls are like a couple right yeah that
was all I heard about is this guy's like
I just liked it the it's like a lesbian
this time I'm like what I mean I mean
they do like it's it's kind of it's kind
of got lesbians in it I guess yeah I
don't know if that's true that's just
what he said and I was like I mean I
mean I mean it's it's like it's like
lesbian or like it's like Yuri in the
same way as like most other Yuri shows
where it's just like there's just two
girls they're just really really get
along they're just really good friends
they're just really good friends like
licorice recoil they're just like the
the main two girls they're just they're
just really really good friends are they
actually gay I'll never tell
we all never tell we'll just hint at it
yeah
um that's up to you yeah but
um no so yeah this is a completely
newbie friendly Gundam so you can get
into this knowing nothing about Gundam I
think it's designed that way as well
um and one thing that Gundam has always
been like one of the main selling points
about Gundam has always been the
politics right and normally a lot of
times it's been about the politics of
War right you have two warring Nations
and that's been a lot of like Mecca in
general uh what I really liked about
um Gundam the witch from Mercury is that
it focuses more on like corporate
politics
so it's set in this world where this
whole corporation like Mega Corporation
controls basically every kind of giant
robot every Mecca that's made huh Google
so Google [__] like imagine if like
Elon Musk yes
imagine if Amazon took over the world
which basically and just start like had
a monopoly on giant robots okay that
would be this like Corporation right and
within this Corporation there's like
Branch companies that Vie for power
within this one giant mega Corporation
right
um and obviously every every different
every different branch companies makes
different types of giant robots and
different meccas and stuff like that
um and obviously there's a special kind
of robot called Gundams using gunned
technology that obviously is like super
[__] op and stuff like that
um and but it got so op that uh they
banned the technology in this company by
kind of like killing everyone off and
stuff like that yeah you know you could
have just like made them unemployed yeah
yeah exactly let's take it out Men In
Black though yeah yeah exactly and I
really I really liked the fact that they
didn't go down the you know they didn't
just go down the wall routes again
because I I found I found like
Gundam when I see Gundam I see like
another War Story I'm like okay I've
seen this I've seen it before in fact
I've seen it so many [__] times
before uh but just seeing them still
have a heavy a show like Stephen
politics but just shift it into like
corporate politics and just like vying
for like power within this big Mecca
Corporation I thought yeah that was that
was that was a that's a really
interesting take like seeing uh like one
scene that stands out to me is like one
of the main characters uh one of the
main girls has to like pitch this
company idea to all of like these Mega
corporations so it's all the leaders of
all the branch companies be like please
invest in my company we're gonna make
all these they basically do a pit like
like a [__] uh Shark Tank investor
pitch just with [__] giant robots and
Gundam and I'm like this is this is
actually pretty cool that's an enriched
that's an original take on Gundam yeah
sure um
like normal story points so like yeah uh
Shark Tank
shark tank with Max uh
and it's just like it's just a lot of
these Branch companies like trying to
sabotage each other
um and trying to make like the best
giant robots uh they can uh it's written
by the same person who wrote Code Geass
as well okay so it's got a bit of like
high school hijinks in it but it's
that's what you expect with like why the
[__] is that high school this is 60 less
excited to watch it because the English
made it sound sick and then you're like
by the way I I did need to mention that
because you know they they needed to add
giant robots fighting somehow you know
because it's a fun high school huh why
High School uh it's a high school where
basically it's a high school
it's a privileged High School where
daughters and sons of all like the
leaders of all these Mega corporations
kind of like send send their send their
kids to this one school and how they
settle any dispute in the school is by
like it's by setting a jewel
they said we should bring that yeah
that's that's how this that's how the
term starts off is that uh one of the
girls is betrothed to one of the uh kids
and betrothed to one of the kids in one
of the others yeah uh and then there's
this main girl who's like comes from
like a peasant family you know like poor
girl and she just like me for she uh she
challenges the guy to a duel and he and
by winning the jewel uh she inadversely
also means that the girl the other girl
is betrothed to her as well because
that's the rules of the jewel that was
set like are they like physical Jewels
or are they like how many stocks and
bonds can I buy anything
that's that's the physical like giant
robot Jewels all right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah I feel like they
added that because they're like we can't
make an entire Gundam just on stocks
[__] we need to add giant robot fights
in this somehow like Gundam fans will
though they will watch stuff as long as
you say they're trading robots I think
Gundam fans are like okay model has
Tesla technology
watches the stocks rise but honestly
it's uh giant robot flights [__]
amazing it's one of the prettiest
looking Mecca shows I've seen in a long
time
um production values off the scale but
also I think more people need to watch
it and I think people yeah are scared
just because it's Gundam and I'm just
like just [__] watch it if they're if
you ever have been curious about Gundams
or if you've it's just been a long time
since you've watched a giant robot show
I think this is like the perfect show
for that yeah I think I think another
big reason why people are scared to get
into Gundam is as you said like it's a
lot of them are kind of like the same
themes and like the same story just like
repackage right like as much as I like
really enjoyed like iron blooded orphans
I will admit I watched it I was just
like Yep this is a Gundam show it's it's
yeah I think that's also the same reason
why I never got as invested in 86 as I
thought I should have I mean I know
Europeans
I got tried
yeah I mean I I enjoyed 86 but like just
it was just seeing like another Mecca
show about war and I'm just like okay
I've seen this before right I've seen
it's like different flavors of the same
thing and not not saying that that's a
bad thing but it's just like a story
that I've seen before so I really
appreciated the Gundam the wish Mercury
like just taking like a different route
two giant robots but still making it
political which is one thing I've
already here's the question is it cannon
with the entire like universe or is it
no it's not yeah it's it's its own
separate right which is why I say it's
like you can jump on right as a newbie
knowing nothing about Gundam right
because it's got nothing to do with it
I'll be honest I probably won't watch
that yeah
I saw like as soon as I mentioned High
School the lights from Connor's eyes
just like [__]
I was already kind of like it sounds
okay and then you mentioned that I'm
like no I'm I'm done no no I don't want
to watch that on the topic of uh High
School anime though I did I did have a I
did have a recent realization myself
what kind of kind of pivoting
um I used to [__] really like the
romance genre
what happened
you got married I think so man I think
he's he's tied up people the options are
close people probably know this already
but it's like my taste in romance anime
and manga is the most skewed out of any
genre yeah I mean you're like yeah
including isekai yeah you know
um I just it's it's weird because like I
just don't think High School romance
anime or Manga just do it for me anymore
even if it's like a really really well I
mean written romance I feel like half of
these romance shows are from people
who've never had a romance it feels like
it feels like that when I watch it it
feels like they've never had like
they're like this is how humans romance
I think right am I crazy like no no no I
feel that I definitely I'm not obviously
I'm sure I mean especially especially
the romance manga that are also
haramonga at the same time are clearly
like from people who are just like who
clearly wanted like they they had a
vision of what they wanted their romance
anymore yeah to me it feels like I'm
just watching a dude's OC fantasy and
like I I just it doesn't feel like an
actual story someone's trying to say
like yeah it's obviously a
self-indulgent thing I mean yeah for
sure I mean like the Target demographic
for the majority of Harem anime are like
you know ages 13 to 50. if I'm watching
a hentai it's a different case of course
different different purpose of drinking
out of it but story-wise sorry are you
the type of are you the type of like
like what would you consider as like the
peak of romance anime in in your opinion
because obviously everyone's answers to
that are always different
um Define Peak what do I think is or
what do you think was like the the best
like I think it's actually come out
quite recently if I talk from like a
Critic standpoint which I do think is
the best romance anime especially High
School romance anime to come out in a
very very long time if not ever it's a
kagya kagya season three has been
like in terms of just an anime
adaptation and just how interesting and
how like the route they go down to
portray this romance I think is [__]
incredible and uh and
the payoff you that has happened at the
end of season three was kind of like
worth all of the investment you put into
or like the previous romance leading up
to that I think a lot of thought has
been put into the characters to make
them not just like because the thing
about romance anime a lot of the times
you see a lot of like one-dimensional
tropes yeah and one thing like surprised
me about kagya is the fact that
um I forgot the uh author's name [__]
um
written by Satoshi oh it's something
what the [__] was his name
um [__] yeah the author of Curry or
someone yeah the author of cargo summer
um he's done he's done a [__]
incredible job at characterizing all of
the different characters and actually
giving them more depth than they
initially feel and having them develop
during the course of the show yeah
um and I think I'll get some are on
paper and as a Critic is one of the best
romance anime manga that has been made I
take domestic girlfriend over that any
day of the week well I would hope so and
that is I don't I just realized that
because I realized
um the most fun I've had like the most
fun I've had with any romance manga in
the past like two years
since the massive girlfriend has ended
it's probably rent a girlfriend oh my
[__] but I think I think I think I think
romance is one of those genres that is
almost more subjective than comedy at
times yeah oh for sure how every person
views romance is so entirely different
and uh I mean it's it's everyone
experiences it in a completely different
way yeah so I think when you're watching
these shows a lot of them are just
trying to like they're like throwing out
their version of romance and whichever
one appeals to the most in terms of an
enjoyment sense yeah and so it makes
sense the domestic girlfriend would be
fun or rent a girlfriend because it's
[__] stupid I mean I I think I think
a big thing uh is that hey I am in a
happy relationship yeah like you know I
want to see another happy relationship
yeah because I I think I think I'm going
to see a [__] car because I'll be
honest I think a big because I used to
[__] love romance anime manga so much
um I think a big part of that was just
the fact that I didn't have any in my
life you know and uh this this year I
[__] finished my romance Arc my own
life I'm like I'm like it's no more
Romance
and I'm like What's Left okay and seeing
a happy couple get together [__] get
that [__] out of my face man that's
boring [__] give me like the spice maybe
you would relate to a story that's more
about when you're married and the
difficulties of that right like maybe
that'd be more interesting and then
maybe but I think it's just something
that
um I don't know to me like I don't want
something like domestic girlfriend or
rent a girlfriend to happen in my life
obviously [__] [__] no that's all well I
would have had to had an intervention of
that yeah yeah exactly exactly but
reading a story about something like
this stuff happens that if that elicits
a stronger emotional response from me
yeah than just seeing a happy couple
gets it it's just like True Crime for
for you it's just a different spin on
True Crime for you white girls have True
Crime and God has domestic girlfriend
it's a different shape
because it's definitely like [__]
rents a girlfriend I'm never going to
say that it is a good manga okay I'm
never going to say that it is a good
romance but holy [__] I cannot stop
reading it it's entertainment it's and
this is like it's not it's not peak
writing but it to me this is Peak
entertainment because I I read every
chapter I hate every moment of it and
I'm like when's the next every morning
no I I I hate every Mo I hate every
moment of it because I'm like all the
characters make me [__] angry yeah
it's the reality TV of romance it makes
me pissed off I need to see the next
chapter right now and I remember I
remember catching up to rent a
girlfriend and I'm like I need more and
that takes skill though I think is an
author to write something that makes you
hate it but also engaged yeah oh
honestly because there's a very fine
line between hating it and then just
wanting to drop it yeah yeah [__] it no
I'm gonna watch it no no I I I think
that I think that is a very fine line
because there's sometimes you see a bad
show and it's just like this is just bad
I just I just I'm just gonna stop
reading and sometimes you see like a bad
show where you you know you see the
characters they make you angry or like
[__] why why why why is this person
being like this or something but there's
something about it that just keeps you
reading even if it's like a hate reads
but but I feel like you say like a bad
show or whatever but like I feel the
moment you're able to elicit any kind of
emotion whether that may be a positive
or negative emotion towards a character
I think that's immediately a good show
because it's like they managed to create
a character that makes you [__] feel
an emotion right like the ones like
almost all of the series that I have
like dropped manga anime in the past are
the ones that just don't elicit any kind
of [__] emotion like there's no
stimuli there where I'm like these are
all just they're all [__] boring like
this it's not even the matter of like I
hate this character or I like this
character like I'm more inclined to sit
around to watch a show of a bunch of
characters I [__] hate than a bunch
of characters I feel nothing towards I
want to disagree with you but I did
watch school days I don't know
that's what I'm saying and that's why I
feel school days gets a lot more hate
that it deserves in that sense because
it's like okay you hated all these
characters but that's a better emotional
response Than A Feeling jumping towards
that character I just helped Joey with
his defense God [__] damn it again I
proved my point once again no y'all
don't listen no because I oh yeah like I
don't want to admit it's good though
because I did catch up to rent a
girlfriend and I was like I need
something else and the what the uh
series I stumbled upon on to like fill
the rent a girlfriend hate hole Yeah uh
or the Spicer I should more call it um
was uh uh quintessential quintuplets
and I remember reading it and I was just
like I mean it's all right
that is definitely the emotion I have as
well yeah I was like this is all right
so if people were like it's all right
um okay question is it is it not
confusing reading it do they not all
look the same no no
um sometimes but like they like
sometimes that's like the butt of the
joke right is that one yeah oh that oh I
thought she was someone else yeah
um my problem is that I it's not that
they didn't look the same my problem was
I just couldn't remember all of the
character names
sometimes if her name was see that's
that's a benefit of knowing Japanese
because all the girls names in
quintessential quintuplets have numbers
in their names
foreign
[Applause]
and I feel it's because like it had just
the right amount for a lot of people it
had like a good amount of you know
wholesomeness like cute like you know
standard you know cut and dry romance
traps but it also in the second half
especially it had a bunch of spice
thrown into it I mean that's kind of why
I read it because that's what some
people told me and I'm just I'm just
like wait what should I be talking about
but like when you it's kind of like
you're it's kind of like your basic kind
of like love like I guess it's like a
love pentagram up no Pentagon
um
the basic love Pentagon yeah I often
find myself in the love okay but I think
I think in the case with for example God
like you read you know you read like
rent a girlfriend domestic girlfriend
right and then you went to Quincy that's
like eating a ghost pepper and then
being like all right let me try this
jalapeno no you know it's like it's not
you're kind of downgrading at that point
yeah yeah yeah it's it's like people who
have like Nando's medium and goes oh
this is uh I can't handle this this is
too spicy I'm like this this is spicy
for you what vanilla sorry like and like
run to your girlfriend he gets like NTR
right yeah that sounds way more
compelling than anything I've ever heard
from any romance I might I want to watch
that I want to see how this man gets
cooked yeah it's I mean I saw it out of
context and it was [__] yeah I saw
the image it looked funny God
that made me want to read it more than
anything else I heard about but but
that's what I mean right it's like even
if it's a negative emotion you feel to
look ridiculous emotion yeah a pretty
[__] giant wrist yeah that's that's
like a huge risk and that draws a lot of
people in being like I hate this I need
more yeah it's it's just and I would
argue that's a good show yeah because I
mean I I understand why you know a lot
of people like shows that are more like
traditional romance and stuff like that
um yeah just I don't know when the last
time I watched one and truly truly
enjoyed one aside from like kagia also
also like nothing ever happens most of
the time in romance shows that's true
and then when it does happen it's always
[__] up and weird it's always like
actually I'm gonna marry a kid and it's
like what like hold on
literally considering like we'll have a
problem actually I'm gonna marry a
five-year-old uh that's gonna be what
I'm doing all right uh you're like you
do your bro yeah yeah what no you no no
no no no no no you do you bro
go to prison bro uh it's like it's just
it's it's yeah I don't know man I
nothing ever happens and when it does
it's it's [__] yeah because at least
with him getting cocked that sounds
funny yeah because
why that's hilarious it is [__]
hilarious following this main character
for like uh how many chapters I had this
realization actually the other day I
realized because you remember Germany
yeah do you remember how do you remember
how it went on for like felt like it
went on for [__] ever oh it was it
was the Avatar 2 of romance yeah it was
like the Avatar Two of romance yeah and
it went on like like did you remember
nisekoi yeah I remember them I remember
everyone being annoyed that nothing
happened yeah that nothing happened yeah
and I realized that
um I realized that nisekoi was like 204
chapters right and I had this
realization died it was long yeah I yeah
it was [__] long I had this
realization that I had read
294 chapters of rent a girlfriend and
it's not even close to being over and
I'm like my images what is this the one
piece of romance anime like I didn't
realize it was it went on for that long
because what I think of long romance
anime with a zero progression I think
nisekoi yeah and I'm like oh yeah that
that was the long show and I realized
that rent a girlfriend is like 100
chapters as well it's always has already
eclipsed that by a hundred chapters and
is still nowhere near like I mean coming
to a club when a lot of stuff happens
you kind of don't notice the length
right yeah if it's dense and and stuff's
always going on you kind of forgive it
yeah yeah yeah and I I I feel like that
that is a lot of that that is a big
problem with a lot of romance anime
nothing happens
that is the textbook example of [__] so
much [__] like at the beginning it's
like all right cool I see this Dynamic
it's kinda cute kind of wholesome all
right let's see what happens yeah and
then you get to like volume eight and
you're just like I can't believe you
guys are still doing the same [__]
because and like another one like
[__] uh you said you caught up to
dress up darling dude yes I was about to
say it like I just I just read volume 10
of my dress up Dolly yeah and I'm just
like this is horring me all over again
bro like it's nothing is oh my this man
has to be gay like they're at this point
don't even bother man like I think
that's the only option
you at this point I just just give up
Mario like it's it ain't worth it bro
yeah it's just and I'm getting scared
like because like the first like four or
five you know and the first like season
of the anime right or so [__] cute
and wholesome and it's like you you were
like rooting for Mario to be like yeah
[__] go for it bro yeah but like my
God from around like volume eight I'm
just like oh no it's starting to feel
like horror Mia yeah it's there's
there's always this let's say Middle
Point in every romance anime where it's
just like okay they hook you with the
dynamic yeah they have like a little bit
of character development and between
their relationship and stuff and then
there's just like a little bit of just
like nothing yeah and then you just wait
until like something big happens yep and
it's just that middle bit that kills me
every [__] time
then once she says corrupted my brain
you should have eight volumes I'm like
oh that's short
that sounds nice
it's still like 100 chapters there's
still something about it yeah yeah it's
ridiculous it's disgusting yeah [__]
one piece man
that corrupts anyone's mind once a one
piece you're always a one-piece fan I'll
get that yeah yeah I know I feel like OG
manga I was also corrupted my brain as
well in terms of what a long manga is
because I realized
um like Shonen Jump manga are a lot
shorter than what they used to be right
because I thought into like I think back
and I think back to the big three
I thought it was a big three bleach
always seemed like the shortest one you
know out of out of all of them right it
didn't didn't
it's uh it didn't and it's definitely
not short on the grander scale it felt
shorter than like let's say my hero
Academia is right for example right to
me it's not saying it is to me looking
back
to like how bleacher fated like my life
and how long I followed bleach it felt
like it was shorter in my mind
um and it's like 700 chapters I'm like
what yeah it's like 60 something volumes
what was bleach was this long what
that's crazy that's just so long yeah
but when but like I remember moments
where like I would read all of bleach
and I'm just like oh yeah yeah like it
was like like you know when I had the
stomach flu I really read slam dunk
right like and and it just [__] flew
by for me it's 31 volumes yeah and I'm
like this does not feel like 31 volumes
like if you think about 31 volumes of
anything that's long yeah but and it's
like almost 300 challenges and I'm like
how did I manage to just like fly by and
it just felt like nothing but then when
I try and sit down and read something
like like my hair for example it's just
like I just want to have a [__] back
to go talk it feels like 900 volume you
just like God stop this character from
doing anything please he ruins the show
so much actually actually I caught up to
the latest why why I caught up to the
latest uh what season are we at right
now we're at season six what the [__]
yeah right we're at season six what yeah
um yeah I mean I'm still here how are
they pumping this [__] up season three
I'm still I'm sitting here still
thinking we're on like season like four
I thought I genuinely I don't even know
[__] I'm so confused okay yeah
I will say yeah I will say to the
Critter of my hero fans it is it is the
strongest season for a while is it worth
catching up to no if you don't like my
hero if you fell out of love with it
would I recommend catching up for this
uh no but what I will say what I will
say now is I'm like kind of prefer
bakugou as the main character oh my God
over Deku Deku the most who sucks the
more seasons yeah go for it I don't
think it's saying that bakugou is better
than Deku is any any credit tobacco all
right decking also [__] sucks
like going into like the later Seasons
I'm like man take it back you has his
problems as a person but at least he's
interesting dude the more seasons I
watch the more I just feel like he's a
[__] wet bag oh my god dude oh he's
just he's just like a song has got that
spice
yeah I mean it might be a pepper Ball
but like it's still small dude I still
look back and that that like three
episode bit with the British bad guy on
her little [__] thing that [__] felt
like 10 years if you haven't watched my
hair again there's just one stupid
Feller Arc with this basically British
man as the villain yeah and his his his
the reason he's a villain is because
he's British um which is fair enough
that's valid uh but it's just like the
longest three episodes of any anime I've
ever watched is that the one where they
like shoe Horner concert scene into it I
think they like try and like maybe I
think they like take up they try to like
invade the school and it was just so it
was again I've never had three episodes
of anime feel so long
it felt it I dude I I've I've read I've
had like I've read one piece like six
hours that went by way quicker than
those three episodes yeah yeah yeah
insane how [__] that show was at that
point I mean I'm sure it's better like I
I mean I I like it felt like at times it
had moments of really good character
writing like when uh a few scenes would
like Endeavor and stuff like that I
really liked how they had kind of oh
they really zoned in in endeavor's
character Arc which for sure which I
knew they were going to do and I really
like that but not enough to get back
into it yeah yeah it's it's weird
because I could see with this latest Arc
that you know they tried to pull out all
the stops everyone gets involved they
know High School hijinks anymore like
thank God every every [__] hero comes
out people [__] die
um people actually die yeah people
actually like God [__] [__] goes down
um shigaraki becomes so [__] opiate I
feel like they made him op for the sake
of just like having to make a really
awesome again he's the kid
yeah and I could see them them pulling
out all the stops and I could see them
trying really hard
but it just something it's just missing
something I don't I don't even know what
it's missing it's just missing
some magic that I can't do you like the
main villain do I like the main villain
the three seasons I watched I was kind
of like who asked I was like
yeah my power is that I can jack myself
off with all these hands it's like okay
I never understood that character it was
three seasons in and I'm still like what
is this dude's deal yeah it's it's it's
pretty weird right because we get to see
his backstory
um I'm not gonna spoil what happens in
this backstory but if you like lay it
out on paper it's actually pretty
[__] dark what happens uh in his
backstory
um and I don't know why it just didn't
feel dark you know it it is something
about it was just like like the
presentation of it
I think it's just because it happened in
the My Hero World there was just this
like this very like uh like everyone's
wearing like a like a mattress around
them at all times right oh yeah oh
you've answered right yeah I mean like
it always feels like everyone's wearing
at home yeah yeah
yeah the um I was watching the backstory
I'm like damn this is this is like some
pretty dark [__] that's happening right
why doesn't it feel that way yeah
why don't I feel like any emotions
towards some of the [__] up [__]
that's happening and then I watched some
some you know and then you watch
something that happens in like one piece
or like one piece which has like a very
let's say it has a unique art style that
doesn't like dark and cartoon yourself
like that and some things happen in them
that's I don't know if it's a me thing
but Eve like when something dark happens
in one piece it [__] it feels dark
yeah you know for sure um even though no
one contrasts on the world pretty well
yeah yeah I don't know there's I I
haven't thought I've put enough thought
into it to really pinpoint what's my
hero in my mind is missing you do the
prize or something how you six how many
episodes is that total how many episodes
is that like 100 plus
I think so yeah yeah holy [__] I salute
you sir you've gone with a few anime
events at the last season I finished was
uh yeah I think after the British guy
showed up that was the last year was
that three or four season three I think
seasons
it's insane to me that I watched four
seasons of that that felt like two so
you are further than I did oh no I feel
like my Approach with anime is a very
similar approach with you like Netflix
documentaries you know I leave it on
yeah yeah sometimes I leave it on and
then the you know if there's boring
Parts in the anime I just it's kind of
just on in the background and I'm like I
can follow with what follow along with
what's going on but like if it's
uninteresting I just don't get invested
and then I come back and sit down when
it's like okay shit's going down now
[__] it's just happening uh at season
six to its season six of my hero to its
uh credit has been like me sitting down
being like Oh I want to see what's
happening because shit's going down
um but it just hasn't hit on the same
level as chainsaw man even [__] Demon
Slayer you know isn't it crazy how my
Academia felt really new and fresh when
it came out yeah and now it feels so
stale and outdated yeah it's kind of
crazy how quickly that happens it's it's
where it's it's nobody talks about my
hair anymore it's very few I feel like
because it's it's being outshined by its
competitors in one aspect like Demon
Slayer I think has less interesting
characters than my heroic characters but
it's the spect score of Demon Slayer
it's just on another level for sure um
and then now we have like Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen and Chainsaw man which I feel
have more interesting ideas and
characters than the whole world of mine
sure as well yeah I think they're more I
think they're more mature and I think
the whole the whole world is just a bit
more interesting than the whole the
world of my hero as well
um there's just so many things
um that I feel my hero is so close to
being a great show but there's another
show that does something better than it
and I just gravitate towards that show
the maturity factor I feel might play
like a big role in it right which is
interesting though because it's like
it's still shun and jump right but like
when you compare it to other Shonen Jump
series it's just something about it is
like
like child not childlike what's the word
cartoonish yeah almost it's like it's
like Saturday morning cartoon Vibe right
yeah I think it's got the training
wheels on yeah yeah it's like I got
murdered and it's like oh yeah oh it's
like you now
my dad poured a hot kettle on my face oh
oh you that's a that's a shame yeah
that [__] would be like like visceral
it'd be gross yeah because you watched
up to like season five of like my hero
right
so you saw some of the Todoroki um
character arcs yeah yeah with some like
you know you think about you lay it out
on paper yeah it's [__] it's like some
traumatic [__] things happened to
Todoroki he got [__] abused by his
dad and his mum his mum [__] burned
his face yeah and I'm like you lay this
out on paper you're like this is pretty
traumatic why does it not feel like it's
that serious yeah it does something
about it just something about it it's
just being like Oh yeah that's just
that's just a thing that happened as
fast oh Todoroki you're poor let's put
some Vaseline on it yeah yeah like if I
could go lost like both of his legs it
would be cute
oh wow oh we used to figure out how to
use his powers differently you know what
I mean like yeah like you know what I
mean it's just kind of like weird how
it's uh it's just yeah yeah how they
make these serious moments feel very
like like I said like safe like it feels
like it's contained in this very safe
confines like yeah scary ideas won't be
explored like yeah bad things will
happen but the implications of those
ideas are never truly like uh like like
Todoroki is obviously like has every
right to be a character that has trauma
but I feel like they never ever really
delved into it in a meaningful way no
he's just I hate I hate my like I hate
my dad I hate my daddy issues yeah well
why don't we like actually just [__]
go into this and how that could actually
impact you obviously right I think it
wouldn't sell manga like talking about
why Todoroki would be traumatized and
why seeing his dad would like upset him
you know like yeah it feels that they
they laid out all the pieces and just
didn't connect them properly it felt
like yeah
and he's sad and he hates his dad yeah
yeah it's it's just kind of like
background noise right I'm like it's not
at the Falls it's like the 15th rent
we've done about my hair again
I feel it's because it's such an
interesting case study in anime where
it's like there is very few it does
everything right but yet it doesn't feel
right right the reason I watched it is
because if I'm gonna [__] talk something
I want to I want to at least have
watched it and so I'm not talking out of
my ass I feel like four seasons I have
every right yeah I think I made it far
enough oh you can you can say blue lock
maybe I don't because I don't know which
one I did a season and a half so that
counts here on trash test we have
uninformed rants about a lot of things
but I refuse to I refuse to bring that
to anime as well man I'm sure this
podcast is the epitome of where's your
souls I made it the [__] up deal with it
can I break the anime talk yeah go on I
did watch some Netflix documentaries
though okay I did and there's one that I
kind of want to talk about it's kind of
interesting
um it was about I don't know if you
heard about this there was a guy in
Denmark who made like his own submarine
okay he ended up up killing someone on
the submarine right but he was always a
guy he's a pretty famous guy in Denmark
he's pretty quirky he's called like
Peter like very quirky okay
commit murder okay
um and I got this documentary was
interesting because the documentary crew
is actually following him for all the
weird [__] he was doing yeah generally
and during the documentary the filming
of it is when he killed someone yeah a
whole show so it's it's one of the like
obviously like this can never happen
because you couldn't have he you
couldn't be like hey that's just film
gone in case he murders someone so that
we have the crew ready to go yeah so
like it's it's like an hour and a half
customers the chase it's really good
it's really just like if you want to see
a documentary about like True Crime
whatever even though it doesn't really
focus on that too much it's just kind of
like showing you the sheer shock of
everyone around the the guy the who did
this [__] up thing oh [__] the [__]
he's a bad thing he did a devious thing
it's a compelling
documentary and just seeing how
this this dude who had built himself up
and was really respected by all these
people who are working with him as like
unpaid interns yeah they all just worked
with him to help make these submarines
for free because they just believed in
it and they're all very close they're
all very close-knit and then he murders
someone and how does he murder them he
so he go he takes this journalist out on
on the submarine and then suddenly the
he comes back up and there's no
journalist on board and then there's a
lot of questions that are like what what
happened right why is that why is the
journalist not on board with you
everybody saw you leave with the
journalist and he's like oh no no she's
fine and everyone's like what what do
you what do you mean and then so they
arrest him because they assumed that
Something's Happened yeah yeah and then
a few days later half a body turns up on
the on like a coastline
and then he says like oh well the the
hatch dropped on her head and I then
shocking and then he and then he
admitted to cutting up the body but he
said yeah I didn't kill her you know and
it's like this whole thing but it isn't
really about that it's just kind of
because they had such an interesting
they were there filming as it all
because the documentary opens up with
kind of like him being arrested and
everyone reacting being like what what
the [__] how did this happen he wouldn't
do it yeah everyone's in denial and it's
just such an interesting look because
you've never ever get to see any kind of
things like this where like every it's
more about the people around him than
him himself yeah and how they're
reacting to this kind of all unfolding
and going from being like no no he would
never do this so were they originally
taking the documentary with the context
of like this is this is crazy dude yeah
right right and obviously they
interviewed him a ton and there's so
much ominous [__] that he said yeah from
these interviews I really feel like
killing someone and he literally
literally he said [__] like that what
and he literally kept being like you
know if you met a psychopath do you want
do you think you would know and he's
just talking about it like that and he's
just like when you watch your back
you're like obviously this guy's on
hinge yeah like obviously when everyone
was around him I was like oh he's a
genius he's a Visionary he's making all
this cool stuff yeah and it's it's just
so fascinating how it you shows the
dichotomy of how
like one moment everyone literally
believes that you're like the smartest
man and the genius and you're just a
[__] crazy dude yeah like you'd
happen to get lucky and people flock to
you and you made some stuff and then
it's someone should keep an eye on you
yeah
making me think more and more about how
we we idolize these really bizarre
people and the bizarre behavior yeah
yeah when it's really a lot of the
majority oh yeah a lot of them are just
like unhinged yeah you know it's obvious
that this guy uh dude and there's some
[__] up stuff like there's one point
in the documentary where
um
one of the interns Masters him and is
like hey I need you to motivate me
because I'm not going to do my work can
you just say you're gonna like you're
gonna like do something violent to me or
something to make me motivated to work I
don't know why
um but he then goes sends her like this
giant essay about how exactly he's going
to kill her and it's actually what he
does later on like to the journalist
it's so [__] and then Christ yeah it's
just all [__] but again it's it's just
so fascinating I recommend watching it
if you really want to
um let me get my Netflix out because I I
should actually do that I'm really bad
remembering the names of shows aren't I
I always do this I never remember the
show's name you know because you've
watched so many I do watch a lot so I
was like it's one of the shows that I've
watched on Netflix I watch the
documentary about the meme guy who
killed you know the ax guy oh I saw that
I watched that too yeah I was gonna
watch that was that one good yeah it's
pretty good actually yeah into the deep
the submarine murder case okay it's it's
an hour and a half really concise gets
to the Point man is it fascinating like
how into the deep was like that sounds
like a clickbait YouTube clickbait title
it's like into the deep that's a good
title that like encapsulates what the
story is about just yeah not clickbait
enough we need murderers dude could you
imagine the subject they're just filming
the life of God and then Gant just
murders someone and you're like what the
[__] you're like wow not a foreshadow
this is a very different documentary now
yeah what the heck yeah that's that's
really interesting yeah that's wow yeah
like I don't recall the time that's ever
happened like where they've been filming
someone just a normal day like filming
them yeah and then they do something
like this I'd like you know of course we
get to this is like reality court cases
like stuff that's like this is why I
really respect documentary makers
sometimes they just go into it and
they're like yeah I don't know what
story we're gonna take we're just gonna
take a [__] risk see what happens
story we can make out of this that's why
that's another good point is that that
it was really fascinating watching uh I
wish them a cafe documentary oh about
dude this is the most [__] insane man
on Earth the stories that come out just
just a very mentally ill man yeah um but
what was more interesting is that the
people who are filming him the whole
time they kept talking about it and dude
man the guy who followed John McAfee ran
was basically just a war photographer he
was like yeah dude you got to be this
[__] insane follower guy like that
because they were like Crossing Borders
illegally and stuff like the film crew
because they're like we want to get this
stuff
we're gonna break the law to get the
footage as well Jesus Christ so like
whenever he did anything batshit insane
the cameraman are doing it too yeah like
when he's illegally breaking it like
Crossing Borders all these cameramen are
doing it too when when he's carrying
guns around illegally they're with them
too right like they take so much risk to
get these like insane shots and stories
and it's so like I just dude I respect
it man like dude anything for the shot
it's insane like these people like War
photographers and War videographers are
the most insane people on earth nature
videographers Yeah man they get like the
most important like footage or uh
pictures that we'll ever like need yeah
for sure I just have so much respect for
documentary Making especially when they
go to that length like that where they
will put themselves in like the most
dangerous situations yeah almost
recklessly you know uh like should
anyone have followed John McCaffrey
around absolutely not but you know I
it's it's interesting getting this but
at least we get to see that side
it's insane someone has to do it to
think that we get to watch that stuff
yeah for sure well it's just like seeing
something like that reminds you what
just like you know pure just pure
journalism is you know for sure when we
think about it it's weird because when
we think about journalism now a lot of
people think [__] either like IGN
articles or just some guy behind a
keyboard who has exposed like a scam or
something like that right but we forget
that there are people who like travel
out like you know areas of conflict War
zones and stuff like that who are like
in real situations of danger and risk
and they do it to get the [__] truth
out and that's [__] insane [__]
Giga chats right yeah hey have you seen
that like one clip of I think it was
like I don't know if it was like it was
it was a reporter who was in a war zone
she gets shot and then she puts on like
a bulletproof uh vest and it just
continues like reporting yeah even
though she just got shot and I'm like
what a [__] badass can you imagine
she's just like it's just like bang it's
like oh whoops forgot to put this on
that won't happen again I apologies
don't worry about it so that was my uh
my weekly recommendation of uh
documentaries to check out damn we
talked about anime holy thought so this
episode is not gonna do well when people
are gonna hate this episode I like it
when they only talk about anime for a
little bit we we did it so the clips
were we needed we need to like
reinvigorate the clips yeah sure that's
true boy the goat of anime
yeah hey look at these patrons though
look at them hopefully they all enjoyed
this full-on do you guys still watch
anime do any of you guys still watch out
nobody watches anime
yeah
because it's the greatest anime I've
ever made
the goat sorry
I thought it should have been called
slash trash taste also follow us on
Twitter sentencing memes on the
subreddit and if you hate her face
listen to us on Spotify and uh yeah
we'll see you again uh for episode 370
when we come back with a full-on anime
episode yes that was our yearly anime
talk guys yeah we filled our quarter we
filled our quota for this year we'll see
you all next time
foreign
[Music]